I love games ready what's up I'm Milo
Mannheim hi Meg Donnelly and we are here
to take the co-star test to see just how
well know each other
their full birthday yes I absolutely
2001. this is July 25th 2000 yep thank
you I try their middle name do you know
like Elizabeth
oh look at us their favorite snack at
crafting Double Espresso and Ice well
definitely these three night shoots that
for sure I'm trying to think what you
get you get coffee too the one day you
had um pizza rolls like pizza rolls no
no like they're in a bag combos combos
that's true I think I can okay well can
I check it with coffee like that's all
you eat and drink yeah it's true their
first job either acting or not I know
your first job you were on that show
what would you do where you were like
put in a situation and you were like you
had to pretend to act to like see if
somebody would do something around you
okay I'm gonna check that Jess um the
show that you're that you did with your
mom yep yeah Ghost Whisperer shout out
David Kelly love you yeah the project
they worked on before zombies three
uh Dancing with the Stars College my was
actually zombies two before zombies oh
yeah I didn't do anything but in between
I went to college yeah okay I went to
college I'll give that to you
um before zombies three you were doing
American housewife yep cool we're
killing it right now the projects
they're working on next
um you just wrapped up prom pact and
then you're working on Disney Doogie how
lizard yeah come out Aloha but okay okay
yeah good job you're working on the
Winchester yes
okay okay the last TV show they binged
watched
blindness if I ordered a piggy blinders
check that box mate what show did you
watch recently I feel like you just like
watched like old like vid like Camp Rock
videos on YouTube that is true for your
free time I feel like I need to say one
thing more or else it's not fair good
okay you watch a lot of like black Pink
music videos this is true
um TV show SpongeBob yeah she's always
been interested
the permission of course their go-to
activity between filming scenes yours is
napping mine's sleeping for sure you can
check that box okay I'm playing games
yeah I'm playing games and labeling
country uh Maps I love yeah I'm a
geography figuring out yeah
I would just name a flag and you would
somehow know go-to activity between
filmic scenes uh hanging out with me
yeah playing games selling on your phone
I know a boring answer but it's like no
I mean that's that's what I did too
their favorite scene they filmed from
any zombies movie okay ain't no doubt
about it yes someday ain't no doubt
about it in someday um you loved filming
bam I did love filming bam I mean all of
these are correct what's your favorite
zombies two I'm I'm winning no no yeah I
feel like you know me better than me oh
oh the stunt that you did on the bus
that was so fun yeah that was my first
day of filming yeah filming crazy Okay
click that button okay your favorite
scene ever is when we were getting Froyo
yes yes that is a cheap cut so the funny
backstory is that I don't know we should
say me and Meg were kind of beefing that
day
we were kind of fighting and then we did
that scene and we had to like
okay so yes I got that okay cool their
giveaway that they're about to break
character and start laughing your
giveaway that you're about to break
character and start laughing is if
you're in a scene with Trevor because
he's always gonna make you laugh I feel
like you go like this you go
stop
stop yeah
stop when I'm about to break up you go
yeah because if you can stop yourself
from smiling then yeah you're like
harder
your dresser must have coffee yeah
always have coffee yours is coffee like
a blanket perhaps yes um your backpack
your laptop I always got to watch the
office while I'm eating my crafty
breakfast exactly their all-time
favorite Disney Channel okay three two
one High School Musical all right that's
a double check they're hidden tunnel you
juggle you catch everything in your like
mouth and you go like that yeah
um you play volleyball
no those are all good you're an amazing
tap dancer we all know
she speaks Japanese no you could
probably recite any SpongeBob that is
true yours like the countries too that's
crazy yeah
13 out of 13. you know absolutely
everything there is to know about your
co-star you've been in each other's
lives for a long time now you either can
finish each other's sentences whoa also
you're basically the same way this is so
crazy because this was like literally
written for us I know and that's so true
we are basically the same person we are
peace everybody thank you so much for
watching make sure you watch the Hobbies
three it's coming soon You're Gonna Love
It mwah
[Music]
um
[Music]